ah ah
[Musique]
regardez la réalité des jours c'est
mignon
il est vexé 120 gardes joie qui effectue
jeudi rend les étoiles que les étoiles
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre
squeeze ouais
[Musique]
politiquement habile et fils tu vois que
je reste exceptionnel il a ouvert une
chaîne sur youporn utilisé
principalement dans les jeux incroyables
tels que aussi regarder ce mouvement
circulaire comme ça montre la puissance
du ch pierre on dire un peu viril avec
les trois tel un petit
thual ou les poignées de vtt ça tout le
monde une quête vous tient dans ta tient
à l'elysée par les unités spéciales des
navy seals pour l'information ouais
c'est génial vous le voyez les comptes
dans ces mondiaux que témoin d'un
symbole sims à la bague en précisant et
si nous avons le plus gros clic al azhar
je m'arrête pas ne m'arrête pas de mal
ça paraît plutôt nul hein ça va passer
d'un maximum n'a jamais pu toi
[Musique]
oh
haha
du bonhomme rouge au front voilà on
revient actuellement de yeah c'était
cool moi c'est un super gentil merci de
poster qui est là qui complique
bonjour à venir je suis celui de lundi
est donc c'était quand même une bonne
journée pour verdir quand même bien que
mon équipe est là monsieur cliquer juste
ici et puis lavaggi liszt mesure en asie
et puis et puis tout logisticiens
mais voilà
et puis voilà
m
donc journée sur le plus tard vide voilà
ça l'est puis à rien
voir enfin debout
on s'y attendait
ça ira mieux après sur youtube voilà on
verra bien
elle est belle tout le monde